denim Alex humble is incorrect leave the
Corning a country pays homage to its
king among the unloaders were host of
world leaders and representatives of the
world's royal houses they all watched as
vilem alexander swore an oath of
allegiance to the country and the dutch
constitution in Amsterdam's new church
he thanked his mother more than anyone
else four men have been held the bills I
have a clear vision of my office no one
knows what the future brings wherever
that path leads and however far it goes
I will carry your wisdom and warmth with
me and you've armed the ignominy the new
king wasn't actually crowned he
officially became king when his mother
signed the abdication act at a ceremony
and the royal palace
and ask my let's today I make way for a
new generation for my son
willem-alexander Villa Malik Samba after
officially taking office the new king
appeared before his people with his wife
queen maxima and Beatrix now a princess
once again more than 25,000 people were
waiting in front of the royal palace for
this moment I think it's a good time for
a change bayit clicks now has time for
herself and the new king is very well
prepared the knee the coating is that
helpful to former heads it's been a
festive atmosphere in Amsterdam as the
Dutch capital rings in a new era for the
monarchy and in a sense everyone feels
like a king